haven't we like this come out in the
fall completely understandable I'm
pretty sure the conversation for the
release date of this movie was something
like this lets us competition some
Sandra Bullock space movie whatever yeah
it sucks for them chicken something that
rhymes with runner so runner runners the
story of Justin Timberlake he loves
online gambling he's one of the guys
gets people to go to online gambling
sites and they give him a commission for
it and then he uses that commission
money to pay for his tuition what we
think is the Dean he doesn't like that
so he's like you're gonna stop and then
Justin Timberlake loses everything on
this side because someone cheated him so
he goes and finds the guy who runs the
site which is Ben Affleck so it's like
hey bat flick what the hell and bat
flicks like you know what worked for me
you'll be my guy it just happens like
that the Vermont osh now he's the guy
and of course Ben Affleck in this movie
he has secrets dirty laundry is
something kind of shady about the guy
and after that there's a bit of conflict
and now it's Justin Timberlake working
for this really corrupt guy who has him
under his wing and here we are and this
movie's not completely terrible it's
just kind of here but the movies a bit
of a mess
that's not no one's denying that's a bit
rushed for sure this movie moves the
plot along so fast it's gonna sound
really bad but it's kind of like one of
my videos so use jump cuts so I can cram
a bunch of information into a couple of
minutes which is fine for a YouTube
video telling you about a movie but when
it's the movie itself that's bad
seriously it is like yeah I have you
under my wing you're gonna be my guy
okay I'm the guy now
Vaughn times you have a bunch of
here are the keys of the kingdom dude I
just met you have the keys to everything
and of course Papa Doc from eight miles
coming after him and he's like dude give
us something against bat flick because
we need to lock him away for a long time
and Justin Timberlake's just like a tick
in a box
really this is one of those movies you
can take it or leave it you've seen
movies like this before Ben Affleck was
really good in the movie I will say that
he is hands-down the saving grace in
this movie he was kind of funny and
sarcastic you feel like a lot of his
lines were ad-libs
I just liked him he was just kind of an
and he was the most enjoyable
part of this movie he brought life to an
otherwise more dull than it should have
been kind of movie I like Justin
Timberlake at this point in movies in
general but in this movie I can take him
or leave him if it was Justin Timberlake
or some other attractive guy
in the lead role in this movie whatever
that flick in this movie is the guy
where I'm like that's great cast
everyone else I'm like all right so I
guess they read the lines the best the
movie is cliche it is predictable there
are scenes he's going into a situation
I'm like I know how this is gonna go
down JJ even gets a beat-down in this
movie I'm like he got off easy really if
you're really looking at people who deal
like the people in this movie Justin
Timberlake would have lost his dick he
would have been Theon Greyjoy and Ben
Affleck would have gotten something in a
box that was not chocolate it's like a
good I have nothing else to see this
weekend so maybe I have free tickets to
go to the movie theater and I now watch
a runner-runner it's always cool to see
people with billions of dollars spend
billions of dollars other than that
though I'm just saying runner runners
alright but you're not gonna remember it
in t minus a couple days yep already
forgot I just can't wait for the next
Man of Steel movie and then Robyn's
bitching about something you see Batman
just in his face alright if you want to
be my partner when Batman tells you to
go out there and take a beating you do
it you come back and say do you need me
to do it again and that will make me
smile alright so what's your favorite
movie where you have a really corrupting
general but I know you know like
Wall Street Gordon Gekko I took that you
can if you want to but I'm taking that
the guy who's like hey I'm the wing of
the Dragon and you're under man it's
warm here I'm a dick in a box whatever
it be comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]